JPJ is the man of the hour if he can
stay awake for it dude I'm so tired
Kalyan confronts Dean the effects
channel aunty chuan wants to go home
this is your bachelor in paradise
episode 7 recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses and roses eh
hi everybody I'm Lauren Zima oh you guys
bachelor in paradise the season is in
full swing and I am feeling great I have
to be honest last week some emotional
breakups and I was feeling all that you
know what it was in me but now it's out
of me and we are just vibing and
thriving in paradise this episode was a
lot of fun wasn't it let me know in the
comments below and everybody to
celebrate bachelor in paradise getting
back into the fun we are getting light
and lively okay this is a brand called
obvious wines this is my new favorite
wine I'm doing something I've never done
on the show before because we are about
trying new things we are about
progressing this everyone is a chilled
red oh yes oh yes it's light its
humorous its bold at the same time so
guys this is one of my new favorite
things a red you can drink in the summer
is a children easy screw-top used to
judge a screw top dome and do it what do
you guys think corkscrew top do you
Karen let me know these are the
important things okay again we are
starting fresh
and Derick path is donning his new day
by digging into a hole yeah I mean it
wasn't a metaphorical dig yourself into
a hole which would have been quite dark
it was just it was a beach hole it was
we're we're getting back to our
childhoods we're embracing our
imaginations we're digging a hole in the
sand on the beach and we're burying our
friend and we're not metaphorically
burying him we're literally burying him
and metaphors can be heavy but sand is
literally not so much okay
so Derek is getting down and moving
ahead try to get out of my head and have
some fun
but while Derek is recovering one couple
may be discovering that they are not as
solid as we thought definitely it's like
when some people are doing well in
paradise other people are in tears and
then now things have switched John Paul
Jones and Asia were smooth sailing while
Derek and Demi were in rough waters well
now JPJ shaaa is under the sea and
Derek's just under the sand they're not
so solid and drink every time someone
says solid fu jizz there someone's who's
so solid and steady before I was like I
see a show it's not so solid and I think
it's like Stella McGarrett were you guys
surprised the Taoiseach didn't seem to
be that into John Paul Jones there's
anybody else you want to see come
downstairs but I will call tisha out a
little bit here
I felt like she went and talked to Jay
PJ and kind of put the onus of her
hesitation on him she was saying things
like well don't you want to try dating
someone else so if someone asks you
what if another woman walked down the
stairs I don't know I just want to make
sure you're happy just leaves me with a
lot of uncertainty in terms of where I
stand with tisha but I'm sure there will
be some more women walking down the
stairs and this show is the gift that
keeps on giving the producers know what
we want someone new come down the stairs
and it's someone very because we have
literally no idea who may remember me
from Colton season I was there for two
seconds like at least with Christian
they could cut back to that footage of
him at the men tell all with t chuan
there's no flashback there's no evidence
that she made it on screen okay but
she's here and you know what we might
not have seen girl on Colton season but
we can't take our eyes off of her on
paradise right now I'm Amy hot but you
know like she's sweating drink every
time she talks about how hot she is
is that Sam right now I'm mainly hot
ridiculous
[Music]
vataj one was cool our conversation
flowed she was very comfortable in her
own skin but that heat combined with
like travel stress she talks a lot about
taking plane rides or plane rides said
apparently her luggage got lost lost
luggage maybe she was supposed to be
here sooner I'm not gonna feel bad about
anything T Schwan's take two in The
Bachelor franchise is not going well but
GC is kind of weird
so it makes sense to me that she takes
JPJ on date they're both so odd they
might be perfect for each other you know
drink for John Paul Jones is grooming
routine that we didn't need to have seen
we see him trimming his chest hair and
he is literally getting dressed in his
ITM sure I know I'm looking for I'm
looking for you while commenting on his
feelings I don't know just making the
best use of its time so he can go take
more naps
you know Teja can handle you know the
stress of you know me sort of just
interacting with another women woman but
you know what as weird as he is John
Paul Jones just gives us so much and as
he goes on this date just drink for
every JP jewel he laughs for no frickin
reason we thought he was smart but he's
confused by the origin of T Schwan's
knee oh my dad's name is Juan Carlos
does he get that one is a Hispanic name
Here I am one like is that associated
with a specific country typically Mexico
yeah yeah yeah my name is Chuck
[Music]
honey wasn't thinking in the food like
and we break the fourth wall and I love
when we do that Sean Paul Jones wants to
eat the date food don't eat it how do
you do you know something I don't know
I'm just saying why - one who has barely
ever been on this show knows you don't
eat the date food we're at a restaurant
did this students this is real food you
guys they feed the contestants
beforehand and I know that might sound
like it's fake but the thing is people
are not attractive when they eat on
camera
so they want the date to be sexy they
don't want them to be eating on camera
and you see how unattractive it is when
John Paul Jones eats on camera you know
what is do not do that what do you even
know what that is
you're one more JP jewel he starts
choking and almost vomiting I mean I
cannot watch him throw up again I cannot
I can't watch it and where can I hear it
no he's not a reality television show I
wonder that a lot he often doesn't seem
aware okay
think he may be just thinks he's hanging
out with his friends on an all-inclusive
vacation you know Cristina the worst
kiss you've ever had worse yes yes while
they're on the date everyone else is
hanging by this bonfire and oh my god a
reveal we didn't see coming
drink every time someone says Colton
Underwood is a bad kisser yeah she was
calling a good kisser
oh this awkward yeah I was not gonna lie
JC's job just drop by the camera at that
golden got called out but Taoiseach I
want to raise a glass to her she does
say that he got better at kissing by the
end of his season she taught him tisha
you're doing the Lord's work anyway
thank you we thank you for your service
I feel really great with Dean right now
like I fully see us leaving here in a
relationship so I'm really excited back
to another couple Kahlan and Dean things
are going so well for them they're all
loved up but whoa whoa whoa at the bar
Denny and Wells are saying things do not
be so well yeah it's really good right
now but I
[Music]
they call Kaelyn out they say look we
know Dean this is Dean's mo he's gonna
make you feel special he has a way of
making people feel really special I
think that she's right he's gonna make
you feel important that he's not really
serious about you okay one kind of
fights them on it but drink every time
they come at her over Dean take a step
back look at it objectively don't do
what every other girl does with him we
raise our head out you need to lay down
the law did you guys agree with them let
me know in the comments below I need to
challenge myself and challenge team and
just have a serious conversation with
him
so Kalyn confronts Dean and asks about
his feelings I just want to know where
your heads up with what exactly though
response wasn't great I mean I'm happy
with this clearly yeah I thought the
mustache was about growth but maybe he
needed a beer too it's challenging for
me to see myself getting to a point
where I'm like alright I'm ready to sell
down now
the thing is though deems honest he's
real about who he is and where he's at
and I applaud him for that he says all I
know is all I know right now is that I'm
enjoying spending my time with you and I
don't want to spend it with any other
girl while I'm here I just want to spend
time with you while were here that's
critical Kaylin it's subtle but it's
critical because he's not saying I
absolutely want to continue with you
after paradise
I don't want it so like
go to dinner parties on Saturday night
and talk about her feeling and he says
he doesn't want to go to dinner parties
and just talk about his feelings I mean
Dean nobody does that
who's going to dinner parties I'm just
talking about feelings is anyone doing
that it's not a new social thing
jaesi are you doing that No so Kalyn
doesn't speak up for herself but her
face does say it all she's like
go ahead it's basically like it
convinced me otherwise situation
and deems like what and it's like I
wanted Kalyn to speak up more what were
you guys thinking in that moment I just
want to k on to end it then and there to
say well I am looking for something
serious you seem to have come to
paradise to just hang out
let's end this but she didn't so JP J
has gone on this date with T chuan he's
unsure about where things stand with
Taoiseach and he just tired really
exhausted that he just exhausted I don't
know why what's he been doing maybe it's
a lot of mental and emotional output for
JPJ drink every time JP j just wants to
take a nap I'm tired you sleepy bro we
exhausted and then someone we do
recognize Haley Ferguson is here she's a
twin from Ben's season her twin Emily's
not here because she's in another
relationship that'd be exciting if we
both got engaged this summer but Haley
is here and whoa whoa whoa JP hey
suddenly the hot commodity of paradise
Haley wants to take him on a date okay
together like couples let's see so the
question again drink every time JPJ
seems unaware that he's on television I
mean Haley asks him who's in a couple
with who and he can't name one couple on
this show like right now yeah I think
it's hard to say
it's hard to say it's paradise doing
this research
like God I mean has he been interacting
with anyone on the beach why is he so
tired
Oh the man's a mystery John Paul Jones
one day how would you feel but it's no
mystery how th Juan feels she is
freaking out about JPJ saying hey to
Haley I'm here to find a man like we did
not come page when you went on one date
you know did you guys think this is
another reaction she keeps talking about
seagulls drink every time she mentions
seagulls
we're both seagulls flying in harmony
and like you're pigeon merciful which
means let's see you go far you're the
pigeon yeah I'm a seagull okay so is
john paul jones were seagulls oh my god
then Haley and John Paul Jones are on
their date and he chokes on the
champagne
I can't is he all right get him a straw
or something you know I need more wine
because I get annoyed with tash whiny
you know she is just non-stop
complaining you're eating spaghetti
alone while in a pool gross
and then she gets me and Haley and JPJ
come back from their date and he chuan
tells her something so offensive T chuan
told Haley that she thought about
spitting and her wine hyperventilate I'm
joking like jumbo jokes why would you
say that taste one taste why taste why
happiness is your choice be
solution-oriented make a friend don't
get obsessed with a man and don't spit
in someone's wine thank you
we're going home but the rose ceremony
is coming and Demi's girl christian says
the thing that we're all thinking how
will the rose ceremony work with Demi
and Christian tonight just confused I
have no idea what a rose ceremony
entails the guys have the roses to give
out so I'm assuming they give them to
the women I don't know it's probably
gonna be the Demi gets to give Christian
a rose they totally loved out they're
totally into each other great you know
paradise is supposed to be about finding
love by the way I interviewed Demi
Burnett about all the Christian stuff
and about the accusations that she
produced herself going on the show with
Christian that interview is available at
E tan line calm shameless plug on like
VIP stagecoach Palin and Blake are still
here and I don't know I'm just a hard
pass on their moment because Caitlin
sets up a VIP stagecoach sing for Blake
and then Blake swing dances with her I
just smack myself in the face over that
I'd rather do that than watch that
moment if I'm being honest he's my best
shot at getting her rose tonight
everybody's obsessed with roses
everybody wants a rose this feels like a
crazy wild card of a rose ceremony
except for Dylan in hand they're really
pretty good to go you know they're
enough okay but back to blatant Blake
does tell Caitlin I'm gonna give you my
rose I defended Christina against
Kaitlyn last week because I felt like
Kaitlyn said some really mean words
about her straight in with her
and you given her a rose got a day sir -
who did you think was the most right
here Kristina
Blake or Caitlin Kristina was kind of
holding it over Blake's head that she
gave him a friendship rose I could see
us around she wanted a friendship rose
but I don't know why she wants to stay
in Paradise at this point like this
shows probably almost over are you
really gonna find love now break was
telling Caitlin that he's all-in
but then he switches on the drop of a
hat to you know giving Kristina his rose
it was just so messy I just want you
know like I'm not sure what I'm gonna do
I'm still kind of up in the air Blake
tells Caitlin he might not give her his
rose and he's like are you blindsided
sorry if it seems like blindsided like I
know I am of course she is blank ten
minutes ago you freaking told her you
were giving her your rose how could she
not be blindsided by that it is a
complete change of fact Caitlin walk
away you know you don't need this happy
birthday
also from Kaitlyn to Kaitlyn it's
Caitlyn's birthday and Dean got her a
cake and that was nice I mean I think it
was last season when Dean got Danielle
Lombard like one slice of cake for her
birthday
am I remembering that right but Dean got
Kaelyn a whole cake it's growth literal
growth from up east to a whole Dena's
whole now baby
hey guys it's me I'm tired because I
just alive to eat movie amazing and VIP
which was weird and confusing and messy
so you know Christina and Blake are a
mess well so am I now I'm drinking a lot
of straight espresso this morning four
shots
I had to vlog because I didn't talk
about what's gonna happen with Dana and
Kailyn tonight it really seems like he's
gonna break up with her on her birthday
doesn't it I just will shave that
moustache of maturity right off Dean
[Applause]
yeah also Chris talks to Jan I do have a
pretty solid Shiva with Katie and Katie
talks to Chris I don't want you to doubt
and Chris is so torn about her isn't
sure I felt like Chris is gonna pick
Katie and the rose ceremony happens and
things pretty much go according to plan
Dylan and Hanna Dean and Kalyn but then
whoa
[Applause]
Blake gives his rose to Kristina buying
a Caitlyn speaking RAF you guys Blake
has so much work to do on himself
doesn't he yeah Katie and Chris gives
his rose to Katie we love it okay what
an episode I love you guys I love
keeping it light and lively here in
Paradise let me know what you thought in
the comments below I am on Cameo if you
want a personal message I adore you we
will be back with another episode
covering Tuesday's episode thank you
guys so much for watching bye
I just realized a head up stick on my
face during that sorry
well this is my desk it's messy I leave
post-it notes for myself those are made
to do lists and then a picture of me my
friend Bryce have cardi B and Kris
Jenner my wine opener of course I'm
gonna Zima the drink and
this is what we tell ourselves about
stress I'm not taking that on
[Music]